the end of another component of all this
processes on the territory of
today's ukraine began to create
anti-russia, these Russian enclaves
that threaten our country, so
our guys who are fighting there protect the
inhabitants of the donbass and defend russia itself, of
course, this deserves all the
support from society, this is very
important from the young  people, well, the
guys who fight there risk their
health and many die
about they must understand what they
give their lives for, this is an extremely important
thing for Russia and for the people who live in the
Donbass,
if not for her age, the world would
not have completely changed
this fans everything else  in the order of
things, this is how it should be, I think there is some
hope that everything will be stable with us,
well, in the economy, in politics, and in
general, that we are protected, we have this
understanding of the standard of living, of course,
it has become a little bit lower, yes, that is,
yes, yes  before, here are the toys, of course, she
’s all that she wanted to buy, now she already
has to  to refuse something about what we
expect this is our protection,
well, we still live here in an enclave, so we
know why he came here, the
situation is such that we are surrounded by
enemies, I think so, and what to expect, he
will come and what will happen and what will happen to me
it seems that people will
calm down, but cats will be stressed, there is, it seems to
calm down, I think, probably, some
economic issues will be resolved,
because I know that they
are trying to limit our bus as much as possible with
these transits and other things,
this issue will probably be somehow resolved so that the
logistics will improve, because I
it seems because of this, prices
have risen on many products and clothes and
so on